(audience applauds)
All right, everybody.
It is time for Drew's News.
It's that good news glue that's holding us all together.
And with me at the desk is
a man that literally holds me together, Rossy Ross Matthews.
(audience cheers)
Hi everybody, hi.
So cute, hi.
Hi Drew.
By the way, congratulations are in order.
Well, we made it to season three, which is like...
Hey!
(audience cheers)
High five, high five, yah.
Not high five, thank God.
(audience cheers and applauds)
The dream.
We're so excited.
And that one, I'm like, okay, yay.
Phew, relief, we're safe.
Relief is such an underrated emotion.
Right?
But this one, I actually feel like
I gotta shout from the rooftops.
So I just found out this morning
that the Webby Awards are coming up this month.
And guess what, Rossy?
I know, Drew.
(audience squeals excitedly)
We are nominated.
This is insane.
This is huge.
For best podcast.
I'm like, it's funny, season three, I'm like,
(pants breathlessly) "Okay, great, we made it".
This one, I'm like, "Woo-hoo!"
Woo.
(audience whoops)
Yeah, It's for Best Podcast.
And you have to see this image,
because I'm in between John Stewart and Stephen Colbert.
Look at you
And I've gotta just say,
#BestSandwichOfMyLife.
Right?
(audience laughs)
So thank you Webbys.
It's an honor to be nominated.
We wanna like show up and go to the party
and just see what happens.
And I'm just, we're the only female show,
interestingly enough.
Yeah.
(audience cheer and applaud)
And the only show in daytime.
All the others are late night,
which also makes me so proud.
(audience applauds)
And you're the meat in that podcast sandwich.
Look at you.
I am the meat.
I'm very excited.
Well, another comedy icon, literally,
I think, a gentleman who has saved all of our souls,
in so many ways, Jim Carey
(audience applause ripples)
has just sort of announced
that he might be ready to retire.
So Variety reports that he says
he possibly might be done with acting.
He's in the new "Sonic The Hedgehog" sequel,
which we'll be seeing opening day, with my girls,
we just went and saw the first one.
And he's thinking it might be his grand finale.
Jim says, quote, "I have enough, I've done enough.
I am enough."
And he says that if the perfect script
dropped down from heaven,
I mean he's had it happen before,
"Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind",
"The Truman Show", "Dumb and Dumber".
I mean the, the-
(audience cheers)
"The Mask".
"Ace Ventura".
Oh my God, "Ace Ventura"!
Oh my God.
He says that he might be open to doing it,
but right now, he's focusing on his painting,
and we have a picture of him painting.
And if he doesn't look cute as a button.
Right?
What's your favorite Jim Carey movie?
Well, I think, I mean, it has to be "Dumb and Dumber"
or "The Truman Show", probably.
Or "Man on the Moon", remember "Man on the Moon"?
With Andy Kaufman?
I do.
(audience applauds)
I do, I do.
There's so many.
What's yours?
I think it's "Dumb and Dumber".
Yeah.
Because Lloyd Christmas is, you know, he's just,
he lives in my heart.
Mm-hm.
I quote "Dumb and Dumber" pretty much
every day of my life.
Give me a quote.
I mean, "Wanna hear the most
annoying sound in the world? (screeches)"
(Ross laughs)
Or, you know, "These Rockies are, you know, flat,
that John Denver's full of beep."
Like, there's...
I always do,
"What's the Soup Du Jour?
The soup of the day.
I'll have that."
"That sounds good.
I'll have that".
That, yeah.
You know, I love Jim Carey and I, as much as I, like,
when I heard he was thinking about retiring,
I was like, no, we need you now more than ever.
But I also kind of love that
he's in this position in his life
where he can just sort of say, I've done that.
I love his quote, "I have enough, I've done enough".
I love him.
I love him too.
And I love retirement.
(audience applauds)
No, I'll tell you.
I do love retirement.
You know, when I'm not,
when I'm not here in New York with you, Drew,
I'm in Palm Springs
and I live my life like an active senior,
I am like,
(audience laughs)
like I wear comfortable shoes.
I have a sensible bedtime.
I mean, give me a Werther's Original and put me to bed.
(audience laughs)
That's how I live my life.
So welcome to the club, Jim Carey,
welcome to retirement.
(bright music)